empieza a la una de la tarde hora de
washington n plenaria del senado
jamie rating liderando los demócratas y
los abogados de donald trump en defensa
del ex presidente debatirán si el
segundo caso de impidió ha encontrado a
otro es constitucional tendrán cuatro
horas para hacerlo y entonces sabremos
si el caso sigue adelante a eso de las
cinco de la tarde hora de washington se
espera esta semana que si es aprobado
este caso de impeachment en el senado
entonces los demócratas liderados por
rating presenten sus argumentos
iniciales tendrán 16 horas para hacerlo
y después será la defensa del oro aunque
tenga también 16 horas para hacerlo se
había dicho que la defensa de tron
porque era judía no iba a trabajar el
sábado pero ya pues quitaron esta
solicitud y están dispuestos a trabajar
el sábado si es necesario ahora
cristóbal los demócratas aseguran tener
una evidencia abrumadora sobre la
culpabilidad del expresidente pero la
defensa de trump
mientras tanto denuncia un proceso
inconstitucional que podemos esperar de
los argumentos de ambas partes
claro los demócratas en un documento de
80 páginas dicen que el único
responsable de lo que pasó en el
capitolio de la toma el 6 de enero fue
donald trump incitando con sus palabras
no solamente en redes sociales sino esa
misma mañana en la casa blanca cuando
invitó a sus simpatizantes a ir al
capitolio y a pues negar los resultados
de la votación electoral en la
presidencia y los republicanos pues en
un documento un poco más corto de 14
páginas se defienden diciendo que pues
ya no hay caso porque el presidente ya
no está en la casa blanca- donald trump
ya salió de la casa blanca y además
dicen que es donald trump tiene todo el
derecho de defenderse y todo el derecho
de expresar lo que él cree sol sobre
sobre todo sobre las elecciones cuando
dice que fue un fraude electoral así que
dicen los abogados de donald trump que
no hay que vincular la violencia de sus
simpatizantes con las creencias que él
expresó ese día antes de la toma del
capitolio cristóbal gracias por
información